[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages time then to see
what's making the headlines with Kev
McGuire associate editor of the Daily
Mirror and Kate Andrews economics editor
of The Spectator and welcome to both of
you so front pages then let's start
shall we with the i the continuing
crisis and the Health Service making
their front page with an exclusive story
they say that the NHS is sending
patients to hotels to ease bed blocking
in hospitals after today's speech by the
Prime Minister saying the NHS will be
fixed along with the country's other
problems but not saying when exactly the
star portrays them as Baldrick in
Blackadder with the headline I have a
cunning plan
the express also leads on that speech
and Mr sunac's five-point plan asking
people to judge him on whether he
fulfills the pledges he's made to fix
the country
it's also the lead for tomorrow's daily
mail Rishi judged me on my five-point
plan
the times likewise makes it their top
story on how Mr zunak plans to restore
British Pride the guardian claims an
exclusive that 122 million pounds worth
of personal protective equipment ordered
during the pandemic from a company
linked to Tory Pier Michelle moan was
unsafe and could have compromised
patient safety and finally although it's
just a little too late for Christmas the
sun has news of a virgin birth in
Peterborough
don't forget scan that QR code that
you'll see on screen during the program
and you'll be able to see the front
pages of the papers while you watch us
and our guests so let's go to Kim
McGuire from The Daily Mirror and Kate
Andrews from The Spectator welcome to
both of you so uh rishi's big pledges we
heard them Kate what did you make of
them and um and how we set them out
well he did lay them out quite clearly
they mainly revolve around the economy
the NHS and immigration and under the
economy you have some subcategories I
pledge to have inflation to grow the
economy and to reduce the overall debt
and I think you can look at it from two
perspectives the first is that in some
ways this was not a very ambitious
speech because the pledges that he made
he's made are following the forecast of
um uh plenty of of the major people out
there Bank of England the CBI the office
for Budget responsibility which do you
expect inflation to fall in 2023 apart
from the bank of England which do expect
to see some growth towards the end of
the year so his pledges do seem to be
following forecasts that are already
made but of course he's gambling on a
lot because some of these things are
completely out of his control the pledge
to have inflation for example is not
within the government's control if it
were they would have been tackling
inflation a long time ago it's very very
politically painful but to tackle
inflation the the main way to do that is
mainly in the Bank of England's
agreement to hike interest rate rates
that's been happening but at a very slow
pace ultimately he's relying on the on
the hope and and the fact that energy
prices have been falling as we found
alternative sources uh since uh Russia
decided to wage its work against Ukraine
um there are a lot of factors that are
out of his control so in that sense it's
bold but if we're being truthful he is
also following the trajectory of a lot
of forecasts that are already out there
well I mean that Stephanie um been one
of the suggestions isn't it um you know
judge me or let's read the express
actually judge me on my pledges to fix
Britain
um but uh it's sort of no parameters on
how to do the judging with no time
frames involved in the in all of this
Kevin
no that's absolutely right inflation uh
Harvard this year he should he should
beat that hopefully he'll beat that
because of course it's still very high
at 10.7 as Kate was saying all the
forecast is going to fall but for growth
uh when when will growth be restored
it's likely to be until 2024 debt or
they've given up on reducing it uh this
Parliament and probably the early part
of the next part should they be
re-elected uh could NHS waiting list
when probably not this year next year
small boats stop uh Small Boat Crossings
well I think that's absolutely
impossible even if he had safe and legal
ways into Britain for some of those
people go in those boats and the others
who knew they would are unlikely to be
accepted they would still try it and it
was rather like it was a weird speech
given that all the billion in advance
was about Mass up to 18 teaching Mass
chapter 18 then it wasn't part of his
his five areas he wants to be uh if
judged on it wasn't his sixth point he
kind of he kind of says it then he moves
on three on the economy the NHS and and
boats and yeah perhaps they are the
areas he should be judged on but I think
he may be judged pretty pretty harshly
and I think that lack of a timetable
when's it when is this going to happen I
think he's left himself incredibly
vulnerable now yes and the times um
Kate's saying that his speech marks the
start of a two-year battle for the
center ground with secure starma the
labor leader some were making his first
speech suggestion that sunak brought his
forward to go first if you like but is
it a battle for the center ground is
that what you're is that what you're
hearing here but from uh from what we
heard from the prime minister
it's too early to say first and foremost
because the speech was vague and second
because uh West labor is doing very well
in the polls a lot of that is due to the
fact that the Tories aren't doing so
well I think it's still very unclear
what the actual labor platform is on
issues like the debt for example would
they follow Jeremy Hunt's new fiscal
rules or would they do something
different would they be more comfortable
with borrowing like Liz trust was or did
the labor party learn the same lesson as
a conservative party uh so I think
there's still some some outstanding
questions as to what they're really
competing for and what the center ground
looks like in the next election
um but the the speech did make sense to
me actually when we think about Rashid
sunak as a politician because something
that he's always done from his time
going in as Chancellor during covid
um up through the leadership race and
all the rest of it is he really does
like to under promise and over deliver
that's been a constant when it comes to
what's been expected in terms of covet
handouts energy support
um his the differences between him and
Liz truss on the campaign Trail when it
came to tax cuts he likes to understate
and then try to over deliver so I wasn't
terribly surprised that we didn't get
some really big and bold promises about
what he achieved for example by the end
of 2023. I think the reason maths was in
there is because
um almost regardless of everything else
it's very clear if you go back to his
maze lecture early last year
um the closest that we've really gotten
to overseas unac Manifesto a personal
one anyway is that he really wants
education to be his legacy almost
regardless of anything else that happens
he's trying to plant education as Jeremy
hunted in the Autumn statement I think
for Rishi sunagas he's done in this
speech as a constant so that when we
look back we see that that was the main
change that he was trying to push while
of course trying to juggle everything
else and I think that the speech was a
reminder to the public that he is
completely aware of what's going on he's
not tuning it out he knows how difficult
times are right now
um whether or not the public will feel
satisfied with his answers to that is a
completely different question but I
think that was the main point of the
speech which is which is I'm here and
I'm focused on this every day and please
don't forget that yes I mean the Daily
Mail to for focusing on the five-point
plan it's an easy hit in some respects
isn't it these you know sweeping
Ambitions you know halving inflation the
like of which you've both talked about
but he did talk to you didn't he Kevin
which is what the the eyes leading on
about the problems in the Health Service
um that they're taking emergency action
that there are challenges seven thousand
more hospital beds new funding on social
care who also talked about strikes
suggesting there's a lot of
misinformation out there was this a
missed moment do you think to really go
into the nuts and bolts of this to give
the government's position on both these
big areas of public concern right now
and actually could have stood there and
explained why nurses can't get more
money and and the ambulance staff can't
go back to work and so on
yeah look the announcements on health
were older being uh they've been you
know said before they were just dusted
down repackaged there wasn't anything
new there uh to tackle that crisis which
is probably why he he moved he moved on
and of course China ban strike while his
scapegoat Strikers in that way Escape
boat workers for much deep-seated
probably seated problems waiting lists
were going up before the pandemic
they're now 7.2 million in England that
nurses and ambulance Crews going going
on strike is partly a symptom of what's
wrong in the National Health Service
it's not just about pay it's
professional workers are very
demoralized about the service they are
working in they can see it isn't
operating fully the times has on strikes
how he's going to set uh the legislation
on minimum service Provisions to force
workers uh in in trade unions to provide
a level of services and say what it is
for instance on the railways said about
20 percent of trains have been brilliant
is he going to sell it 40 to 50 it'll be
legal Challenge on that can you actually
force people to go to work when they
voted to strike and cleared incredible
legal hurdles that exists and it it
seems it he isn't really tapped in the
root cause of why people are going on
strike you just stay dry I'm going to
try and ban it in whatever way I I can't
I just don't think that was a
particularly clear speech perhaps it
would have been the speech he might have
been the center of a speech he might
have made that last October's
conservative conference so we haven't
been rejected by the Tory party members
uh before he was brought back after Liz
trust crashed and burned uh so um
spectacularly inexpensively over 44 days
I just don't think he has sharpened the
focus of the the public I just do not
feel he's going to change politics with
these pledges yeah I'm jumping about a
bit here and showing the time because on
the right hand column they've got a
story that these strike laws could be
enacted as soon as uh Thursday employers
the paper says we'll be able to Sue
unions and Sac staff under government
plans to curb the right to strike the
times has been told Rishi sunak poised
to announce legislation to enforce
minimum service levels in six sectors
including the Health Service rail
education fire and border security and
the laws which will be announced as soon
as Thursday will require a proportion of
union members to continue working to
attain a minimum level of service as you
said Kevin go for it yeah I'd like to
announce them on Thursday doesn't mean
they will be in in force on Friday
because I imagine the legislation will
have to go to the House of Commons and
House of laws it'll be a pretty Fierce
parliamentary debate on this
particularly if he tries to to rush it
and I think it's fundamentally unfair
and just anti-democratic what he is
doing but even his supporters I think
will have to concede it's unlikely to
impact on the current wave of disputes
yes and they quote here Tim sharp senior
employment rights officer at the TUC
saying the measures are unworkable
counterproductive and almost certainly
in breach of the Human Rights Act of
1998 so uh let battle commence on that
one um I think meanwhile let's go back
to the eye cage and this is very
exclusive that um three NHS authorities
have signed deals to discharge patients
to so-called care hotels now if you
listen to radio phones many people have
said why don't you bring back like
Nightingale hospitals to put those who
are nearly well enough to go into their
own home but not quite into those places
and the message has come back there's
not enough staff to do that someone
wonders how you get staff to fill these
hotels to take some of these patients to
relieve um the bed blocking issue
oh there's a major question around staff
whenever we're talking about up in
capacity it's one of the major issues
currently in the Health Service uh but I
I imagine that the government has
crunched the figures this is only
speculation and decided that it will
inevitably be cheaper to use rooms that
are already available and to try to
staff and then it will be to try to
recreate the Nightingale hospitals those
were done very efficiently and very
quickly it was an absolutely massive
undertaking
um you know the story speaks to a major
problem with the NHS which is that
social care and for the better part of
the decade has just not been included in
that discussion and I think when we look
at some of the mistakes of previous torn
governments it isn't that they haven't
been increasing the money that goes to
the Health Service every single
government has in real terms some
certainly more than others like Boris
Johnson's but it's that social care for
a long time was not part of the
discussion one of the major issues we
have now is up to 13 000 beds are
suspected to be occupied by people who
could be leaving hospital but aren't
leaving hospital yet it's difficult to
discharge them and often once they're
discharged it wouldn't necessarily be
safe to send them right back home there
needs to be some kind of medium term
situation made out for them and that's
something that the government's trying
to handle now
um and of course that 13 billion pounds
extra that has been pledged for social
care down the line most of that is
currently going to the NHS right now and
so the money that was supposed to be
there for social care is there for
playing kova ketchup at the moment which
means that again it is just
um an underappreciated area of of what's
causing a lot of the problems in the
health service at the moment yes in the
who warning about intense pressure from
covid a new variant as well obviously um
flights coming in from China too which
is you know raised some concerns and
just on this one uh in the eye um this
is in the southwest of England could be
expanded to other parts of the UK
suggestion that hotel stays would be
expected to average four weeks and age
UK saying hotels are not appropriate for
elderly care but could be the lesser of
two evils so we'll see just one sentence
Kevin
yeah it seems to be two two parts of
Devon and one Cornwall and they seem to
be private care hotels so it's not just
like a Travel Lodge or a you know a
Premier Inn but it does there is a huge
problem of in in the NHS of getting
people out in Social care and the
government can't after 13 years wash
your time and not take some
responsibility for that it's it's had
time to fix it and it hasn't okay
interesting story that one anyway we'll
see how that goes both of you stay there
thank you very much lots more to come
including the front page of the times
world or the inside Pages rather at
times well their headline Republican
Rebels dig heels in over the speaker
despite Trump's appeal to them back with
that in just a moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview with me once again Kevin
McGuire associate editor of the Daily
Mirror and Kate Andrews economics editor
of The Spectator
um Kevin let's go to the guardian um
shall we and this is continuing uh
issues surrounding the conservative peer
Michelle moon and the supply of PPE
no absolutely you've been some fantastic
reporting in the guardian by David
Cullen and this and the PPE Scandal more
widely I got to say by private eye and
the uh the Sunday Times but this is at
122 million order for for gowns that
went to PPE Med Pro after lobbying by uh
the Tory P Michelle man they couldn't be
used because they weren't sterile
amongst other issues it's why the
government the department for Health and
Social care is now suing to try and get
the money back and of course we know the
police are investigating and National
Crime agencies raided homes and there's
allegations that moan and her husband
took a huge amount of money from uh from
that through um trusts in the Isle of
Man and of course wrong wrongdoing is
denied it's going to be said in in in
fairness but you know the the whole
right in covert there are many many
scandals to come out on the supply of
PPE and VIP Lanes perhaps some people in
this case moan lobbied Michael Gove
amongst others they seem to get very
favorable will treating big contracts
for delivering is the accusation yes and
certainly the guardian saying that moan
had previously denied via her lawyers
that she had any involvement in the
company so uh that is uh that's her word
on it
um in the meantime um you're home for
the holidays Kate uh dodging the extreme
weather in the U.S thankfully
um but with the BDI no doubt on what is
happening in the House of
Representatives where this crucial role
of speaker is is seemingly undecided
after six votes tell us more
there's only one story in town at the
moment the Republicans took back the
House of Representatives and what was
otherwise quite disappointing midterm
election for the Republicans and what
was expected to be a straightforward
vote returning the minority house leader
Kevin McCarthy who represents California
into the majority house leader uh 20
Republicans who are considered to be on
the right of the party are blocking this
vote they're voting for a congressman
from Florida
um Byron Donalds and uh they have now
gotten to the sixth ballot and it has
failed yet again
um and all of America is watching and I
think it's quite interesting because
um Donald Trump who these 20 right-wing
Republicans many of whom very much
support him has actually gotten involved
and said look you know you guys just
need to get this done please just get
Kevin through
um and they're actually saying no and I
think it's very interesting to see the
way that the Republican party is
splitting the fractures that are there
their big questions we're already
talking about the 2024 general election
the presidential president election and
I think they're really big questions as
to what the Republican Party stands for
who they're willing to unite behind and
also who they're willing to listen to
because there was a time not too long
ago where these right-room Republicans
would have certainly gotten on board had
Donald Trump said so and the fact that
they're not now I find very interesting
as well so a lot of different factions a
lot of political debate a sixth ballot
that has failed uh and the whole nation
is watching really asking what is the
Republican party what is it going into
the next election
um and and what do the different
factions look like and I think we're
learning a lot about that through these
failed ballots which are a bit
embarrassing for the party frankly very
interesting to follow lots of political
drama to be had absolutely first time in
100 years the speaker's not been voted
in on the uh or got the gavel in the
first vote and I think it was 1856 it
took 103 33 rounds which we haven't got
time to report for a Massachusetts
representative tour to get it let's hope
he doesn't last that long we will see
thank you both very much indeed